last week Netflix released the new  season of stranger things that's a big  yeah and and this season is packed with  even more 1980s pop culture references  yeah in fact I love the show but I think  it can be a little too much at times for  example season 1 of stranger things had  this great spooky theme song that  everyone loved but I guess the show's  creators decided it wasn't 1980s enough  so they changed it for season 2 they  have a new opening now I think it was a  mistake  take a look  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hopper Nancy Paul Reiser but lucky  [Music]  waking will I mean willing Mike and they  can you add no teeth and then got some  teeth but now it looks like he's going  [Music]  if you like me  [Music]  you  [Music]  you